you have a 15 year old daughter so I'm
gonna do a little et research here does
she have a crush on no ascent nao from -
all the boys I've loved before I think
she's more into Obama like it's smart
guy not I mean he's probably very smart
- yeah I'm just saying the rom-com is
one of Netflix's most viewed original
films ever and only ET on lions Katie
Krause was invited to the Vancouver set
of the highly anticipated sequel
I feel like Noah became sort of the
Internet's boyfriend if you will what is
the weirdest question or funniest
question that you've gotten about him
people ask me like what he smells like
what do you say oh good
oh my going it just smells good smells
good looks good in fact it was kind of
almost perfect in our exclusive sneak
peek at the sequel 11 o'clock 11 o'clock
there's just one problem I could stick
around and help clean up no I think I
can help my girlfriend you know yep it's
a love triangle
Howard lejana handling all of this all
the guys Oh fighting over her who do I
think is dream eaters
hi China hustle sure yeah good luck
because it's gonna get testy sometimes I
wish my boyfriend is more anonymous if
he's the head that wears the pants what
the sequel explores is just the fact
that relationships can get be a lot more
difficult you know especially once
you're in them for real not know these
things to all the boys PS I still love
you arrives just in time for Valentine's
Day and the third movie in this series
is officially ago but Noah's also
getting buff for another project
transforming Frankie man
how are you I mean what is that like
it's a lot of eating oh that's awesome
like what do you eat you would think
it's awesome but it's like 6,000
calories a day the average person is
supposed to eat like 2,000 calories a
day
[Music]